can you see a rate hike this year or
possibly even next year well I would say
with certainty we're not going to say
rate hike in July and we probably won't
say rate hike in September let's see how
the world progresses I think they've
always saw their data dependent so
there's still a I would say a modest
possibility they would they can still do
a 25 basis point tightening in December
if not we'll have to see I actually
believe the brexit will lead to more
uncertainty it will lead to modestly
slower growth so I'm under the opinion
that it's highly probable they are not
going to do any more tightening this
year Janet Yellen and her colleagues on
the FOMC have faced a lot of criticism
over that data dependency point people
argue that the data were there and that
the Fed should have raised interest
rates at some point over the course of
the first two quarters now that we've
seen the brexit and furthermore the
financial market volatility in December
through to mid-february can we look back
and say they were right to keep their
feet on the gas pedal and to keep
interested in to keep monetary policy as
loose as it is they'd be in the Fed
being right yes absolutely I did I don't
agree that they should have tightened I
don't think the data is entirely there
we still have modest inflation we have a
weakening economy you know they revised
the first quarter from one to 11 we have
actually weakening corporate profits and
so you add that up I actually believe it
was appropriate for them to pause now
what happens to the other central banks
with this uncertainty Draghi failed to
mention mr. Draghi of course governments
have been unwilling to act thus far as
you pointed out we have elections coming
up action is going to be months or if
not many quarters away so they've been
vast criticism of the ECB policies
within Germany and other part of you I
think that criticism is going to abate I
believe the brexit and the all the
uncertainty it will allow the ECB and
Mario
more freedom and flexibility if they
need to be providing more stimulus sure
but in the we know now that stimulus
look what happened in Japan more
stimulus in the form of negative
interest rates doesn't always deliver
the desired outcome I'm under the view
negative interest rates it produces
negative outcomes it's it's that should
not be a surprise especially in places
of Japan and Europe it was a mistake in
other words I personally believe
negative in Judaism are a mistake big
mistake in Europe you're actually seeing
more lending you've seen a a modest
increase in lending the problem is i
actually think its depressive to
consumer confidence because in japan in
europe the majority of society are
saving in the form of bank deposits and
bonds when you have negative interest
rates you're harming these savers you're
harming their ability to save to live in
retirement so what they mean it means
they have to save mark it means they
consume less